all right big news guys so you already
know that uh my book johnny the walrus
is the number one best-selling uh
children's book it's one of the one of
the best-selling books in the country
and it's a huge smash hit sensation well
i woke up this morning and discovered
that um
my book not only is the number one
best-selling children's book but it's
also according to amazon the number one
lgbt book in the country that's what
they they put it they have their lgbt
charts and i'm the number one lgbt book
in the country uh and this is this is
this is huge i mean this means that i am
now
i guess a leading member of the lgbt
community i take that responsibility
very seriously it also means you can
even hear the birds the birds are
celebrating this morning uh my book
johnny the walrus about about a boy who
identifies as a walrus but it also means
that i'm exempt from all criticism now
uh you cannot criticize me given that
i'm an honorary member of the lgbt
community fact if you uh criticize my
book
if you don't buy my book you are now
officially homophobic so go to
johnnywalrus.com and buy it now